so the poster came out for saw X and it
looks like this and it's very much in
line with the posters for the original
saw Saga where most of them have a white
background with some kind of disturbing
imagery and the classic saw logo some
people were asking me if I really
thought that there were going to be like
a split storyline to where we have stuff
going on in the present and then we're
looking back at the main storyline with
John Kramer in between saw one and two
and I think that was mostly just wishful
thinking this is probably just going to
focus on John there's a reason that
they're bringing back Tobin Bell and
Shawnee Smith for this they're trying to
recapture the energy of those original
Saw movies so I think any hopes that I
had of this touching on the Present part
of the timeline was mostly just wishful
thinking that being said I'm always
looking forward to a new saw and there's
no reason that they can't revisit that
future storyline a little bit later or
maybe even set stuff up for it in this
movie I think despite whatever you think
about jigsaw that Logan Nelson is a
really cool character and I do want to
see them revisit him in the future let
me know what your thoughts are in the
comments